alors qu'il fait face à une vague de
démission depuis qu'il a pris les reines
de Twitter Elon Musk fait une nouvelle
fois parler de lui cette semaine Donald
Trump va bien faire son grand retour sur
Twitter Fanny pour éviter tout
incitation à la violence depuis l'assaut
du Capitole l'ancien président américain
a donc pu faire son grand retour sur
Twitter un retour rendu possible grâce à
un simple sondage posté par Elon Musk
demandant à ses abonnés s'ils souhaitait
le revoir sur la plateforme mais Trump
n'est pas le seul à bénéficier de
l'arrivée d'Elon musk suspendu après des
propos antisémites le rappeur Kanye West
a pu lui aussi faire son come back en
postant ce tweet test je regarde si mon
compte est débloqué alors êtes-vous
d'accord avec le retour de Trump et de
Kanye West sur Twitter
alors allez très rapidement est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord ou pas qui oui à toi
oui toi ouais mais en fait Donald Trump
ça l'emmerde la décision parce que il
avait écrit son propre réseau social il
a emprunté un milliard d'euros donc il
voulait pas du tout revenir sur Twitter
donc son compte a été activé lui il a
pas du tout tweeté en fait ça l'emmerde
plus qu'autre chose de revenir sur
Twitter oui parce qu'en fait il a il a
un réseau social maintenant qui
s'appelle social truech
la vérité sociale
et il a fait un tour de table pour
réussir à monter ce réseau social et
donc il doit à ses actionnaires
absolument avec qui il a monté ce réseau
social une exclusivité et donc il doit
d'abord écrire sur ce réseau social ou
il n'est suivi que par 4 millions de
personnes alors qu'il est suivi par 83
millions sur Twitter mais il doit
d'abord écrire et éventuellement 6h
après peut-être il a le droit d'aller
sur Twitter merci moi je suis scandalisé
Kanye West anti West antisémite
réintégré c'est honteux franchement
c'est rien ne peut excuser ça voilà
faute grave alors qui est d'accord
qui était aussi voilà 13 et je trouve
que faire du buzz comme il l'a fait là
il a fait 15 millions me coups de buzz
en réintégrant des gens qui sont
antisémites pour moi c'est une vraiment
je suis d'accord avec toi bah voilà
les réseaux sociaux c'est la liberté
donc si vous
voulez
vraiment vraiment on va voir ce qu'il va
dire
la question c'est sur deux personnes moi
que Trump je m'en fous ça a été un
président des États-Unis donc il est
retourne pourquoi pas que Kenny West il
retourne tout de suite je suis pas
d'accord et en fait il aurait dû faire
il aurait dû faire il aurait dû faire
Donald Trump
la production et et voilà ils sont
finirants ils ont fait les deux en même
temps on va pas se raconter d'histoires
c'est une question de fainéantise voilà
donc voilà on dit des choses ici ouais
ils sont dit bon on va mettre les deux
ensemble voilà comme ça ce sera fait
surtout que la messe est un danger
public merci alors elle est un gros
problème avec la raison est-ce que c'est
lui qui décide de qui a peur de la
liberté d'expression donc lui c'est ça
va être le nouveau chef du bien sûr
Trump et au-dessus tout le monde et
c'est lui qui va dicter les règles pour
moi il sera jamais
Daniel moi je trouve que c'est très bien
pour la liberté d'expression il y a
tellement il faut faire il faut faire
attention il faut mettre deux moyens il
faut mettre plus de moyens pour un vrai
un espèce de gendarme de Twitter s'il y
a des propos antisémites racistes ils
seront euh
mais je suis désolé il faut arrêter tout
le temps et on s'en fout c'est facile
tu peux tout dire raciste
on sanctionne si c'est sous le coup de
la loi il y a aucun souci et il faut
mettre plus de moyens ça j'en suis je
suis sûr mais je suis désolé il y a des
menaces de mort toute la journée qui
passe crème et on empêche Donald Trump
maintenant
je dis dans sur mon facebook Macron et
je suis bloqué 15 jours non mais moi le
problème moi je dis makroud
et j'ai Mokhtar qui c'est vrai qu'ils se
connectent directement tu dis Mélenchon
vous voulez réagir là dessus non danger
public moi je suis d'accord mais au
moins il a un visage découvert et on le
voit que c'est un danger public moi je
préfère ça plutôt que des gens qui font
qu'on quand on s'en rend pas compte par
exemple sur nos écrans fumée la série
sur Netflix mais on se rend compte qu'on
est manipulé sans le savoir là le gars
bah on voit clairement ce qu'il fait il
agit publiquement et moi ça me dérange
moins que quand c'est c'est fait de
manière
c'est cette expérience ton pantalon
ce qui m'énerve c'est cette espèce de
censure à géométrie valable si on
censure Donald Trump si on sent sur
Kanye West faut qu'on se censuré tous
les contres racistes antisémites bien
sûr c'est la meilleure solution c'est de
ne donner aucun crédit assez tweets on
s'en fout de ce que tu dis ouais tout le
monde s'en fout